if a person's identity depends on
qualities that can crumble he or she is
in danger of despair for without a sense
of self we are nothing and the world is
unmoved by our existence if everything
should fade what will be left of me we
live in fear of this loss of self our
existential crisis and could look at Ile
I come from Mirror a land of nights my
sword is always ready there is only one
way up in mirror join the order and
prove yourself in battle my family had
little fortune and no name
I had to carve out a piece of the world
for myself with two things my sword and
my loyalty to my lord I was raised to
wield a sword from birth life was hard
but I never gave it a second thought I
had swift success on the battlefield and
quickly attained respectable stature and
then high and then I came here - who are
you
we came to drangleic seeking answers our
flesh like many others of humanity is
branded with the dark sign of the undead
while marked an undead memory of their
humanity will fade until only a hollow
husk remains on death robs us of our
past and in doing so it robs us of our
fate
Lucca till was marked and she bears it
with shame but it forced her out of her
homeland across many kingdoms the
appearance of this curse and those who
bear it has been met with fear and
hatred the king of iron bound the undead
in Chains and tortured them endlessly
the current king of light did much the
same sending them to an inescapable
Bastille it is not so strange to think
that the land of Mira would have reacted
in much the same manner damning Luka
till if it was ever discovered what she
had become have you heard of the undead
he's poor souls affected by the curse an
undergraduate loses his humanity until
his wits degrade completely finally he
turns Hollow and preys upon others and a
hollow can never be human again one can
skirt this wicked fate only with the
help of the souls found here assuming of
course that the legends are true I can
only hope that they are the mask hides
Luca Till's shame it is said the
drangleic holds the souls that can cure
the curse many adventurers rose to the
call some driven by greed others by
desperation for Luca tale drangleic
holds salvation I found my thoughts
growing hazy my memories are fading
oldest first curse is doing its work
upon me
I am frightened terribly so if
everything should fade what will be left
of me existential despair the curse took
her knighthood the thing she devoted her
life to Lucca deals self was based on
her prowess as a knight and her loyalty
to her Lord forced to leave the
drangleic what does she have left she
will lose herself given time she will
lose that which made her what she is
oh you my thoughts are very scattered
what is this curse
the question rings in my mind but I
haven't a focus to answer it loss
frightens me no end loss of memory loss
of self if I were told that by killing
you I would be freed of this curse then
I would draw my sword without hesitation
I don't want to die I want to exist I
would sacrifice anything anything at all
for this it shames me but it is the
truth
sometimes I feel obsessed with this
insignificant thing called self
even so I am compelled to preserve it am
I wrong to feel so surely you do the
same in my shoes
maybe we're all cursed the moment we're
born all of us face this same despair
cursed or not there is no meaning in the
world beyond what meaning we give it
despite this we seek meaning for a life
free of purpose simply means that we are
able to imprint our own we are all a
product of our past and this shapes our
future but an undead is doomed to lose
his past and thus fated to be robbed of
his future Luca tiel has one hope to
find her past and recover who she was
I had an older brother we learned to
fence together he became the most
decorated swordsman in all of mirror
I never even compared to him in fact I
never beat him not once but then one day
he was gone lost without a trace now I'm
certain that he was taken by the curse
if only someone would hear my tale my
brother must have come here too soon I
may forget even about him an undead
gradually loses his humanity until his
wits degrade completely finally he turns
Hollow and preys upon others you what's
become of you oh my dear brother
I won't die in this foul place
who are you Oh No
forgive me I know you yes of course how
go is your journey we find Luka till
here after her help in countless battles
and right before her finding her brother
it is assumed that they have fought but
it is not known perhaps she never met
him
perhaps it's better that way for he has
lost himself and attacks others to rob
them of their humanity regardless Luka
till never progresses further so it is
here outside of Al Diaz keep that her
journey ends I know not what you seek in
this faraway land but I pray for your
safety my name is Luka till I beg of you
remember my name
for I may not myself
existential despair is a universal human
condition there is no meaning in the
world and yet we seek it insatiably hey
guys if you like that video then you can
click the bonfire and become a part of
the small group that supports this
channel it takes you to patreon where
you can give a dollar or two dollars a
month to get rewards like seeing videos
early and it really helps me out and it
keeps this channel going so thank you
for watching and I'll see you next time